there's a lot of uh books written about
you there's a there's a book invent and
wander where uh Walter Isaacson does an
intro and it's mostly Collective
writings of yours um I've read that I
also recommend people check out the
founders
podcast uh that covers you a lot and it
does different analysis of different
business advice you've given over the
years um I bring all that up because uh
I saw that
there uh I mentioned that you said that
books are an antidote for short
attention
spans and I forget how it was phrased
but that when you were thinking about
the Kindle that you're thinking
about how
technology changes us yeah we co-evolve
yeah with our
tools so you know we invent new tools
and then our tools change us which is
fascinating to think about it goes in a
circle and there's some aspects you know
even just inside business where you
don't just make the customer happy but
you also have to think about like where
is this going to take Humanity if you
zoom out a bit 100% And you know you you
can feel you your brain brains are
plastic and you can feel your brain
getting reprogrammed I remember the
first time this happened to me was when
Tetris who first came on the scene I'm
sure you've had that anybody who's been
a game player has this experience where
you close your eyes to lay down to go to
sleep and you see all the little blocks
moving and you can you're kind of
rotating them in your mind and you can
just tell as you walk around the world
that you have rewired your BL brain to
play
Tetris and but that happens with
everything and so you know one of the I
think yeah we still have have yet to see
the full repercussions of this I fear
but I think one of the things that we've
done online you know and largely because
of social media is we have trained our
brains to be really good at processing
super short form content and you know
your podcast flies in the face of this
you know you you you do these long
format things and uh reading reading
books is a long format thing and we all
do more of if if you if something is
convenient we do more of it and so when
you make tools you know that we carry
around um a little we carry around in
our pocket a phone and one of the things
that phone does for the most part is it
is an attention shortening device
because most of the things we do on our
phone shorten our attention spans and
I'm not even going to say we know for
sure that that's bad but I do think it's
happening that's one of the ways we're
co-evolving with that tool but I think I
think it's important to spend some of
your time and some of your life doing
long attention span things yeah I think
uh you've spoken about the value in your
own life of
focus of singular focus on a thing for
prolonged periods of time and that's
certainly what books do and that's
certainly what that piece of technology
does
I